[Música]
Hola Muy Bienvenidos a directo cop 27 el
espacio en el cual les contamos lo más
relevante de todo lo que ha sucedido y
sigue sucediendo en la Cumbre climática
de la ONU que se lleva a cabo en egipton
y la noticia de este evento es que ha
sido postergado la presidencia de
egipcia que lidera la Cumbre anunció que
las negociaciones Irán Hasta mañana
sábado Aunque varios negociadores
estiman que se podría prolongar hasta el
domingo como lo conoció nuestra enviada
especial a charleshake María Clara calle
Buen día María contanos qué ha sucedido
y en teoría hoy deberían haber acabado
las discusiones aquí en la cop 27 sin
embargo la presidencia ya prolongó
oficialmente las negociaciones Hasta
mañana cuando se espera que salga las
discusiones o el resultado final llamado
cover decisiones Cuáles han sido los
puntos de más división los países en
desarrollo exigen que se cree un
mecanismo para financiar las pérdidas y
los daños que deja la crisis climática
los países desarrollados se oponen a
este mecanismo y sin embargo hoy lo
nuevo Es que la Unión Europea accedió a
la creación del fondo a cambio de que se
aumenten las ambiciones para reducir los
gases de efecto invernadero y que además
se incluyan otras fuentes de dinero para
meter por ejemplo a los privados esto
por qué bajo el pretexto de que los
países desarrollados no tienen
suficiente dinero para financiar este
fondo además ellos quieren que se
incluyan otros grandes países como china
e India dentro de los contribuyentes
para analizar este tema y en qué van las
negociaciones nos acompaña Gina Cortés
ellas punto focal de el grupo que lidera
las discusiones de mujeres y género Gina
bienvenida y cuéntanos en qué radica
estas divisiones de pérdidas y daños las
divisiones radican principalmente en el
hecho que países desarrollados no
quieren tomar su responsabilidad por la
deuda histórica y ecológica que han
causado esta crisis climática no han
tomado responsabilidad y por el otro
lado de lo que están haciendo es
trayendo nuevos mecanismos de
financiación que lo que van a hacer es
perpetuar esos ciclos de deuda que ya
estamos viendo como por ejemplo en la
región latinoamericana y en otras
regiones están limitando el espacio
fiscal para que los países puedan
entonces avanzar en acción climática
desde soluciones que son propias del
territorio y lo que vemos en contraste
Entonces es también una discusión de
esas soluciones falsas que no han sido
probadas soluciones que son riesgosas
como lo que es la captura de carbono o
la geoingeniería que estamos viendo que
está cooptando este espacio cada vez más
y más y más y son soluciones que en
realidad ponen en riesgo los derechos
humanos tienen el riesgo de desplazar
poblaciones en distintos regiones y
además también seguir subordinando a la
mujer en toda su diversidad dentro de la
acción climática el tema de pérdida hace
años es importante que tengamos Claro
que se necesita establecer como tal esa
ese mecanismo financiero Hoy acá o este
fin de semana acá porque no podemos
contener en un diálogo en un diálogo de
los diálogos cuando ya vemos que los
impactos del cambio climático están
Ahora son presentes y no podemos seguir
en eso y ahora precisamente que
mencionas a las mujeres una de las
discusiones que ha dilatado el cover
decisión o el resultado final es género
que está pasando en temática puntual y
cuáles son las diferencias en el tema de
género hay una frustración muy grande
hasta el punto de que todas las
activistas organizaciones feministas
trabajando en género trabajando en
mujeres estamos empezando a perder el
sentido de este punto en la agenda a
quién le sirve porque no se están
entendiendo y no se están integrando las
lecciones aprendidas de por ejemplo la
pandemia cuando se vio tan claramente
como las crisis pueden perpetuar y
exacerbar esos impactos diferenciados en
la mujer ahora es muy probable que nos
vayamos de la Cup sin una decisión de
género y esto se posponga hasta junio
que por un lado está puede ser negativo
Pero por el otro lado también hay otras
opiniones que es mejor no tener una
decisión una conclusión en esto que
tener una mala que no va a avanzar hacia
la equidad de género y esto es algo que
va muy ligado al todo el contexto de la
Copa donde en este momento se está
retirando de ese cover decisión el
lenguaje en cuanto al derecho a un
ambiente sano seguro y sostenible en
cuanto en el momento en que los Derechos
Humanos no son integrados como el eje
central que nos va a llevar a sección
climática y géneros o parte de eso Y a
qué se debe esta falta de consenso a los
intereses es una falta de voluntad hay
un interés muy muy fuerte interés
principalmente privado interés
principalmente corporativo que se está
tomando esta
conferencia este espacio de toma de
decisión política como una oportunidad
de incrementar los negocios de abrir más
espacio en los mercados y a la
acumulación de capital hablando de
transiciones justas No desde una
perspectiva de equidad y desde la
población sino desde Cómo podemos
cambiar un negocio por el otro y eso es
algo que tenemos que estar muy
pendientes de lo que va a pasar porque
por ejemplo en el tema de transición
justa no es pasar del Carbón a pasar a
explotar litio nuestros territorios Hay
que ser muy pendientes con eso y es algo
que acá dentro de la copa estamos viendo
cada vez más como este espacio está
perdiendo el propósito para avanzar
hacia los derechos humanos y es algo que
como
activistas organizaciones feministas
indígenas juventudes estamos trayendo
siempre a la mesa y Aquí vamos a seguir
en resistencia hasta que esto no sea
claro Gina Gracias por estar con
nosotros y lo veremos precisamente Cuál
es la decisión y la inclusión final en
el cover decisión sigan ustedes con más
María Clara calle Muchísimas gracias por
otro completísimo reporte desde Egipto a
nuestra audiencia la invitamos por
supuesto a continuar en la pantalla de
France 24 para conocer todas las
noticias internacionales y
principalmente todo lo que está
ocurriendo en la Cumbre climática de la
ONU en su tramo final marcado por muchas
insurtidumbres y faltas de consenso
sigan en transmite 4
[Música]